pues hay que resaltar que venezuela
nicolás maduro ha apoyado abiertamente a
vladimir putin en su duración a ucrania
así que de pronto más que un mediador
venezuela es una oportunidad de
seguridad energética para potencias como
rusia y eeuu de hecho hay que resaltar
que en este momento venezuela produce
800.000 barriles de petróleo al día esto
es mucho menos de los cerca de 3
millones de barriles de petróleo al día
que llegó a producir hace unos años así
que venezuela también está interesado en
esta puja por la seguridad energética de
las grandes potencias en reactivar su
industria petrolera y por ende apela a
estos diálogos con rusia y con eeuu para
que haya inversión en la industria
petrolera venezolana y puedan llegar a
esos niveles de producción que pues
antes producía venezuela hay que
mencionar también que pues muchos
analistas en eeuu están diciendo que
precisamente estos acercamientos de
asesórese y de altos oficiales
estadounidenses con maduro concretamente
a partir de esta reunión lo que están
haciendo también es acercar más a
venezuela a eeuu entonces ganarle esta
carrera energética de seguridad
energética e incrementar la presencia de
eeuu en venezuela teniendo en cuenta la
alta influencia que tiene rusia en este
momento en el país venezolano también el
presidente colombiano se reunió con
biden porque terminan estos países
sudamericanos siendo importantes en
medio de una guerra en europa y qué más
dijo y bando que tras la reunión
es precisamente esta necesidad que
tienen los países los grandes países
poderosos del mundo de asegurar su
oferta energética pero tras esta reunión
usted lo mencionaba se designó a
colombia como miembro de lo que no hace
parte de la otan mayor miembro no aliado
de la otan y también se pues resaltó el
presidente iván duque que ha recibido
llamadas de líderes de rumanía de
estonia y de polonia para pedirle ayuda
y asesoría sobre la crisis migratoria
que ellos están viviendo en este momento
de cara a la migración de refugiados
ucranianos esto teniendo en cuenta la
experiencia que tiene el gobierno
colombiano de cara a la ola migratoria
de venezolanos en los últimos años a
territorio colombiano el presidente y
bando que no se quiso referir al hecho
de que estos oficiales estadounidenses
hayan viajado a caracas y dijo y resaltó
en varias ocasiones que la relación
entre eeuu y colombia es muy buena y lo
seguirá siendo
los próximos años como aliados
estratégicos